[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Wahlsonntag
Christian Otto liefert den Formel 1
Weltmeister dazu genau Max Verstappen
hat es wieder geschafft guten Abend und
das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
nach Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
Ministerpräsident weil und seine SPD
klar vor der CDU grüne und AFD legen
deutlich zu die FDP muss um den Einzug
in den Landtag zittern
nach Sabotage und Bahnchaos weil ein
politisches Motiv nicht ausgeschlossen
wird ermittelt jetzt auch der
Staatsschutz
und nach chaos-rennen und viel
Verwirrungen Red Bull Piloten Max
Verstappen wird vorzeitig Formel 1
Weltmeister zum zweiten Mal in Folge
[Musik]
die Wählerinnen und Wähler in
Niedersachsen setzen in der Krise auf
Bewährtes die SPD von Ministerpräsident
Stefan weil bleibt trotz
verlustenstärkste Partei und bekommt
vielleicht sogar ihre wunschkoalition
mit den Grünen die haben nämlich
deutlich dazu gewonnen wie auch die AFD
CDU Spitzenkandidat und Parteichef
Althusmann hat wegen des schlechten
Abschneidens seiner Partei vor ein paar
Minuten seinen Rücktritt angekündigt die
FDP fliegt vielleicht sogar aus dem
Landtag gehen wir direkt ins
zdf-wahlstudio zu Matthias Fornoff
Matthias wie sehen die neuesten Zahlen
aus ja guten Abend hier ist die neueste
Hochrechnung für 19 Uhr demnach kommt
die SPD auf 33,2 Prozent verliert aber
gegenüber von vor fünf Jahren die CDU 28
% mit noch deutlicheren Verlusten die
Grünen 14,0 auch mit zu gewinnen die FDP
5,0 auf der Kippe ob sie reinkommt
verliert relativ tatsächlich die AFD
11,7 Prozent mit deutlichen Zugewinnen
und die Linke 2,7% definitiv nicht im
Landtag vertreten die sonstigen 5,4
Prozent zusammen und jetzt schauen wir
mal was das heißt für die Möglichkeit zu
regieren hier in Niedersachsen die
Anzahl der Sitze die man braucht für die
absolute Mehrheit ist diese senkrechte
Linie 68 die amtierende große Koalition
käme auf 91 das wäre also rechnerisch
gar kein Problem die Frage ist aus
politisch gewollt ist Rot-Grün 69 knapp
drüber würde reichen Schwarz-Grün würde
nicht reichen und wenn denn die FDP drin
ist wir haben es gesehen das ist knapp
dann ginge auch Jamaika haarscharf
die SPD ist wieder stärkste Partei wie
ist das zu erklären allein durch die
Popularität des Ministerpräsidenten
na das ist sicher ein Faktor Stefan weil
hat hier einen klaren Amtsbonus gehabt
bei den Wählerinnen und Wählern in
Niedersachsen die allermeisten wollten
ihn behalten und keinen Wechsel hin zum
CDU Herausforderer aber man muss auch
sagen bei den drei Top-Themen die die
Leute hier nennen das ist
Energiesicherheit wie in ganz
Deutschland das sind die explodierenden
Preise und das ist aber auch Schule und
Bildung bei allen drei Themen steht die
SPD vorn was die Lösungskompetenz
betrifft es ist also eine Mischung aus
Personen die funktioniert haben und
Kompetenzen Dankeschön Mathias Fornoff
Niedersachsen war das letzte Bundesland
das von einer großen Koalition regiert
wird und dieses Bündnis dürfte jetzt
wohl auch bald beendet sein wir gehen
wieder ins ZDF-Studio nach Hannover zu
Bettina Schausten die jetzt den
Ministerpräsidenten und einige der
Spitzenkandidaten befragt Bettina so ist
es das gehört natürlich zu Routine des
wahlabends dazu da wollen wir die
Reaktionen hören und wir beginnen beim
Wahlsieger des heutigen Abends bei
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil Herr
weiger großer Erfolg zum zweiten Mal
wieder gewählt können Sie jetzt in eine
dritte Amtszeit starten und haben die
Wahl weiter mit der CDU oder eben den
Grünen das reicht läuft es jetzt auf
rot-grün hinaus ich habe vor den Wahlen
ja gesagt was meine bevorzugte Präferenz
ist das ist Rot-Grün das haben wir aber
eben auch gesehen na das könnte durchaus
der knapp sein und die Niedersachsen
kennen wir durchaus auch lange
wahlabende aber wenn es danach reicht
dann bleibe ich bei meiner Präferenz für
eine rot-grüne Landesregierung
weiter mit Bernd Althusmann
Spitzenkandidat der CDU der heute Abend
schon die Konsequenz aus seiner
Niederlage gezogen hat aber sie waren
angetreten um Stefan weil hier als
Ministerpräsident abzulösen der
Althusmann das hat nicht geklappt die
Wähler haben sie auf Platz zwei
verwiesen was sind die Gründe für diese
Niederlage und sie denken auch nicht
mehr an eine große Koalition
man darf hier nicht schön reden das ist
eine bittere Niederlage für die Union in
Niedersachsen wir wollten stärkste Kraft
werden dieses Ziel haben wir nicht
erreicht wir haben ein engagierten
Wahlkampf geführt sind aber mit unseren
Themen offensichtlich nicht
durchgedrungen unter Umständen könnte
natürlich der Amtsbonus das wurde schon
erwähnt ein entscheidender Punkt gewesen
sein in Krisen dann versammeln sich
viele Menschen dann doch hinter dem
Ministerpräsidenten das ist ganz
offensichtlich über Jahrzehnte in
Deutschland so aber ich sage auch
kritisch wir müssen als CDU in
Niedersachsen wie auch er als CDU in
Deutschland etwas tiefer schürfen wir
können die letzte Bundestagswahl und ich
denke auch die letzten 16 Jahre der
CDU-Regierung auf Bundesebene nicht
einfach ausblenden auch das war Thema
immer wieder im Wahlkampf und insofern
ist es uns nicht ausreichend gelungen
mit unseren Vorschlägen zur
Bildungspolitik mit unseren Vorschlägen
für ein Energieland mit unseren
Vorschlägen für eine starke Wirtschaft
in Niedersachsen so zu punkten dass wir
vor der SPD gelegen hätten und bei mir
kam hinzu ich bin ja
quasi Regierungsmitglied und aus der
Region heraus Opposition zu betreiben
das ist schon ein echter Spagat gewesen
also insofern ich schaue optimistisch
nach vorne wir werden uns neu aufstellen
als CDU Niedersachsen und bekanntlich
ist die nächste Wahl dann ja gar nicht
so weit entfernt danke Bernd Althusmann
ja den Platz an der Seite der SPD wollen
jetzt die Grünen einnehmen kräftige
Zugewinne für die Grünen
Julia Willi Hamburg ist die
Spitzenkandidatin sie haben ihre
Präferenz für ein rot-grünes Bündnis
schon im Wahlkampf wirklich nicht
versteckt melden Sie heute Abend noch
ihren Anspruch an oder schon ihren
Anspruch an auf ein Wirtschafts- und
klimaministerium bei Herrn Wald nein wir
warten jetzt erstmal die Wahlen ab aber
sichtbar ist gerade nach den derzeitigen
Erkenntnissen dass die Wählerinnen und
Wähler sich für eine rot-grüne Regierung
in diesem Land entschieden haben dass
wir diese dann auch hoffentlich bilden
können und damit Bund und Land Hand in
Hand die Menschen gut durch diesen
Winter und durch die Krise führen werden
und ich freue mich über unser historisch
bestes Wahlergebnis und über diesen
Rückenwind viele Leute an den Ständen
haben mir gesagt Sie wollen dass die
Grünen mit regieren wir hoffen dass wir
das dann jetzt auch einlösen können und
die nächsten fünf Jahre Niedersachsen
dann zukunftsfähig aufstellen vielen
Dank Frau Hamburg die grüne
Spitzenkandidatin zu Gewinne auch für
die AFD während die FDP hier ein sehr
bitteren Abend erlebt Reaktionen von
beiden Spitzenkandidaten hat mein
Kollege Peter Kunz im Landtag
eingefangen
Stefan matsischewski von der AFD 12
Prozent das Wahlergebnis fast verdoppelt
mit welcher konstruktiven Politik wollen
sie dem Wähler des Vertrauen jetzt
belohnen konstruktiv das was ich gesagt
habe Politik für die Bürger vor Ort
machen zum Beispiel die Tafeln vor die
Tafeln vor Ort finanziell unterstützen
unser Wahlversprechen möglichst auch
umsetzen das heißt die
Straßenausbaubeiträge abschaffen und für
bessere Schulen sorgen und für mehr
Sicherheit im Land Niedersachsen also
hier ganz ganz explizit was für das Land
Niedersachsen tun
Stefan Birkner eine Zitterpartie für die
FDP was heißt das für sie was heißt das
für Herrn Lindner in Berlin wenn Sie
hier Niedersachsen rausfallen würden net
ich gehe davon aus dass wir demnächst
niedersächsischen Landtag angehören
werden und darauf konzentrieren wir uns
und das heißt dann zunächst einmal dass
wir alle Voraussicht nach in der
Opposition unserer Arbeit fortsetzen
werden so wie wir das in den letzten
Jahren auch getan haben als engagierte
politische Kraft
ja letzte Frage wie immer an den Wahl
Gewinner und Ministerpräsidenten Stefan
weil im Bund liegt die SPD bei 17 18
Prozent sie sind der Mann für 33 müssen
sie jetzt auch mehr Verantwortung auf
Bundesebene übernehmen werden sie ja
weil jetzt sowas wieder reservekanzler
nein ganz bestimmt nicht ich habe
eigentlich auch unter schon ganz anderen
Bedingungen immer darauf hingewiesen
dass mein Platz in Hannover ist und es
hat noch wenige Abende gegeben wo ich
das so direkt gefühlt habe wie diesen
aber ich werde natürlich auch gerne
weiter mein Teil dazu beitragen dass die
SPD nicht mehr in Niedersachsen
erfolgreich ist sondern bundesweit und
darauf können sich alle verlassen ich
stehe für ein sehr pragmatischen auch
für ein hoffentlich bürgernahen
politischen Kurs und ich bin ganz sicher
auf diese Art und Weise können wir
überall auch Punkten gerade auch in
schwierigen Situation
herzlichen Dank Herr weil herzlichen
Dank an alle Spitzenkandidaten das ist
der Wahlabend in Niedersachsen zurück
nach Mainz ins Studio zu Barbara Hellweg
Dankeschön nach Hannover für den Moment
danke Bettina welche Signal geht von
Niedersachsen nach Berlin aus vielen
galt diese Wahl als Stimmungstest für
die Ampelkoalition besonders die FDP hat
heute eine Quittung bekommen die auch
die Atmosphäre in der Bundesregierung
belasten dürfte hier die Reaktion aus
der Hauptstadt
diesen Sieg haben unsere GenossInnen
Genossen in der SPD in Niedersachsen
geholt und er ist verdient wir sind auch
in diesem Wahlkampf als eine SPD
aufgetreten Schulter an Schulter Land
und Bund die gesamte Parteispitze war
mehrfach vor Ort es ist für uns kein
schönes Ergebnis wir hätten uns wir
hätten uns gewünscht dass wir diese
Wahlen besser abschneiden dass wir das
Vertrauen gewinnen es ist nicht gelungen
wir haben trotz widriger Umstände das
beste Ergebnis voraussichtlich wenn es
so bleibt was wir je hatten in
Niedersachsen das ist ein riesen
Vertrauensvorschuss dafür haben wir uns
zu bedanken aber das ist auch ein großer
Auftrag dass wir auch regieren und
dementsprechend ein riesenglückwunsch an
unsere Leute in Niedersachsen vor allem
unsere
Spitzenkandidatinnen Julia Hamburg und
und Christian Meyer die die hier die
Lokomotive waren für diesen Wahlkampf
wir haben hier im Prinzip eine klare
Kante gezeigt und wir haben ja
Alleinstellungsmerkmale gehabt indem wir
unsere Politik aufgerichtet haben an die
Ursachen die wir derzeit die
Preissteigerung was Inflation angeht was
Energieknappheit angeht klar benannt
haben und nicht bloß an den Symptomen
herumgedocktert haben mit irgendwelchen
entlastungspaketen und Versprechungen
der Regierung es ist ein Rückschlag für
die FDP-Frau Schausten das ist völlig
klar wir wollten dass die Politik der
Mitte gestärkt wird in Hannover sieht es
jetzt aus nach einer linken Mehrheit
übrigens hängt das wohl auch damit
zusammen dass die Union vor allen Dingen
Wahlkampf gegen die FDP gemacht hat
nicht gegen SPD und Grüne wir haben
bundespolitisch unseren Wahlkämpferinnen
und Wahlkämpfern aus Berlin aus der
Ampelkoalition heraus auch keine
Rückenwind geben können denn viele
unserer Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer Fremde mit dieser Koalition
Niedersachsen hat gewählt ein Signal
auch für den Bund Analysen
Einschätzungen und natürlich alle
aktuellen Entwicklungen an diesem
Wahlabend finden Sie online in der ZDF
heute App
wer steckt hinter dem zugchaos von
gestern Polizei und Deutsche Bahn gehen
von Sabotage aus mittlerweile hat der
Staatsschutz die Ermittlungen übernommen
da ein politischer Hintergrund nicht
ausgeschlossen wird an zwei Orten hatten
Unbekannte
Kommunikationskabel durchtrennt und
damit den Zugverkehr im Norden
Deutschlands weitgehend lahmgelegt
Patricia Wiedemeier berichtet
es sind düstere Szenarien jede
Umspannstation jedes Kraftwerk jede
Pipeline könne attackiert werden könne
ein mögliches Ziel von Sabotage sein
warnt bundeswehr-general Carsten Breuer
nicht nur die Bahn sondern die gesamte
Energieversorgung könne damit gefährdet
werden in einem Zeitungsinterview
spricht er davon dass man sich hier im
Kommando vor allem auf Hybride
Bedrohungen einstelle das ist der
Zustand zwischen nicht mehr ganz Frieden
aber auch noch nicht richtig Krieg
gestern bei der gesamte Zugverkehr im
Norden lahmgelegt durch Sabotage am
Kabelnetzwerk der Deutschen Bahn im
Berlin wird heute über die Konsequenzen
diskutiert
die Dienste und die Polizei müssen den
Schutz der Infrastruktur in diesem Land
in den Mittelpunkt schieben wir brauchen
mehr Geld dafür wir müssen Bund und
Länder besser miteinander verzahnen und
das ist dringend notwendig dass jetzt
ein Gesetz auf den Tisch kommt den wir
mit der Miteinander in der Ampel
vereinbart haben um das alles zu bündeln
und da muss die Innenministerin jetzt
liefern die Union fordert mehr Schutz in
Zeiten neuer Gefahren mehr Geld für die
Bundespolizei
wir sehen dass beispielsweise solche
kabelsysteme und kritische Infrastruktur
nicht wirklich gut geschützt sind
deswegen muss man vielleicht auch über
den Einsatz von Drohnen oder auch
Sensortechnik in Kabelschächten
nachdenken und jedenfalls sehen wir dass
es notwendig ist doch weiter intensiv in
die Bundespolizei zu investieren klar
ist aber auch eine hundertprozentige
Sicherheit für die Infrastruktur kann
und wird es wohl nicht geben
Österreichs Bundespräsident Alexander
van der Bellen wird voraussichtlich
weitere sechs Jahre im Amt bleiben bei
der Präsidentschaftswahl erreichte der
frühere grünen Politiker nach ersten
Hochrechnungen klar die absolute
Mehrheit der 78-Jährige tritt als
unabhängiger Kandidat an und wird von
fast allen großen Parteien in Österreich
unterstützt
jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine einen Tag
nach dem Anschlag auf die für Russland
so wichtige krim-brücke sind die
Reaktionen in der Ukraine zweigeteilt
die einen fürchten einen Racheakt des
russischen Präsidenten die anderen
bejubeln die Explosion als Zeichen
russischer Schwäche und Bestätigung der
eigenen militärischen Erfolge Alissa
jung berichtet aus Kiew
Kiew am Wochenende fast fröhlich und
ausgelassen der Angriff auf die
krim-brücke ist für viele ein Grund zum
Feiern
ein weiterer kleiner Sieg für uns wären
wir auf den ganz großen Sieg warten das
hat uns glücklich gemacht es war ein
guter Morgen
doch in die Freude von Viktor und Ina
mischt sich auch Sorge wie wo und wann
wird Putin sich womöglich rächen
im Hinterkopf haben wir das immer
und die Lage gerade ist nicht einfach
wir wollen aufatmen aber es ist noch
nicht die Zeit für große Feiern
fährt man raus aus der Innenstadt nach
irpin ist die Hölle der russischen
Besatzung im März noch überall sichtbar
viele haben Hoffnung dass die Ukraine
nun auch im Süden immer mehr Boden
zurückerobert
ich dachte niemals dass ich mich über
den Schaden oder die Niederlage von
anderen freuen würde aber das ist eine
gute Sache für uns
es ist gut für uns weil Russland nun
keine Ausrüstung mehr über die Krim
liefern kann
unklar ob die Metro recht behält laut
russischem Verteidigungsministerium
läuft der Zugverkehr wieder wie diese
Bilder zeigen sollen viele Familien in
irpin wie Alexander und Marina bauen ihr
Zuhause wieder auf die Angst dass die
Russen wiederkommen könnten ist aber
nicht weg
wir wissen dass es jederzeit wieder
passieren kann ein zweiter russischer
Angriff
neben hier heißt hoffen und Wangen
liegen ganz nah beieinander
wer Frauen und Mädchen auf der Straße
verprügelt der steht auf der falschen
Seite der Geschichte sagt
Außenministerin bärbock mit Blick auf
Iran in der Bild am Sonntag kündigte sie
an weitere Sanktionen gegen die
Verantwortlichen durchzusetzen
unterdessen reißen die Proteste nicht ab
gestern Abend gelang es offenbar
Aktivisten sich in die
Nachrichtensendungen des
Staatsfernsehens einzuhecken schließt
euch uns an und erhebt euch war am
Bildschirm zu lesen
dieser Jahrestag mahnt uns nie
wegzuschauen das twitterte heute der
Bundeskanzler drei Jahre nach dem
antisemitischen Anschlag auf eine
Synagoge in Halle die Stadt und die
jüdische Gemeinde gedachten der Opfer im
Hof der Synagoge der Anschlag habe das
Land verändert sagte
sachsen-anhaltsministerpräsident
Haseloff ein schwer bewaffneter
Rechtsextremist hatte 2019 vergeblich
versucht die Synagoge zu stürmen
anschließend erschoss er zwei Passanten
die steigenden Preise sind vor allem für
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen
bedrohlich auch für viele Studierende
die jetzt ins Wintersemester starten
Beispiel Mieten im bundesdeutschen
Schnitt kostet ein 20 Quadratmeter
WG-Zimmer jetzt 9,4 Prozent mehr als im
Vorjahr in Berlin sind das im Schnitt
487 Euro in München sogar 545 plus mehr
Kosten für Lebensmittel und Energie über
die Sorgen der Studierenden berichtet
Sven Regen
Studentin Katharina Müller lebt in
Hamburg in einer Dreier-WG in der
Heizung und Strom gerade teurer wurden
es gibt eigentlich kaum eine richtige
Möglichkeit noch Energie zu sparen ich
glaube wir leben schon sehr sparsam
machen alles zusammen kochen zusammen
auch in Katharinas WG kam gerade die
Nachricht des Gasversorgers an 75 € mehr
im Monat da reichen die aus dem
Entlastungspaket der Bundesregierung
gezahlten 300 Euro für Studierende nicht
aus ehrlich gesagt geht die dann auch
direkt wieder für die Semestergebühren
drauf also das waren jetzt an der Uni
Hamburg auch fast 300 Euro das
überschneidet sich das Studierendenwerk
hat angekündigt die Essenspreise in der
Mensa zu erhöhen sollte es keine
weiteren Hilfen geben kritisch für
Studierende schließlich war die
bafög-anhebung gering an bafög-aufschlag
gab es knapp sechs Prozent die Inflation
liegt bei 10% und wir wünschen uns
einfach ein Automatismus so dass das
BAföG genau in dem Maße wie die
Inflation auch angepasst wird 40.000
Studierende zählt die Bürger Uni 160
Gebäude gehören dazu die brauchen Wärme
und Strom auch das kostet viel mehr Geld
als öffentliche Einrichtung können wir
dieses Geld ja nicht sozusagen
erwirtschaften an der Stelle sind wir im
Gespräch mit der mit dem Senat der Stadt
Hamburg hier gibt es auch noch gewisse
Offenheit aber es gibt auch hier
Hoffnung dass wir da unterstützt werden
lieber kältere Hörsäle als keine
Vorlesung Katharina müller geht
allerdings auch deshalb häufig in die
Uni weil es dort wärmer ist als in ihrer
WG zumindest noch
jetzt zum Sport und einer Silbermedaille
die sich fast wie Gold anfühlt absolut
verdient tolles Turnier die jungen
Deutschen Tischtennisspieler sind auf
ihrem Erfolgsweg bei der Mannschafts-WM
in Chengdu ihr erwartet im Finale von
Gastgeber China gestoppt worden freuten
sich aber dennoch über Silber
Europameister dank Schuh gelingt für
Deutschland gegen Marlon der einzige
Satzgewinn im Finale
doch der Olympiasieger ma behält die
Oberhand China gewinnt alle drei Einzel
und kommt zum 22 Team WM-Titel die drei
deutschen Spieler erleben ihr erstes
WM-Finale Benedikt duda und Junioren
Europameister Kai Stumpe verlieren
jeweils deutlich und sind dennoch
überaus erfolgreich ohne die Topspieler
Timo Boll Dimitri ofcarov und Patrick
Franziska gewinnt ein deutsches
Männerteam zum vierten Mal WM Silber
seit 2010
in der Fußball-Bundesliga verbessert
sich Borussia Mönchengladbach durch das
5:2 gegen Köln auf den sechsten
Tabellenplatz der FC rutscht runter auf
der Niederländer Max Verstappen ist
erneut und vorzeitig Formel 1
Weltmeister nach einem schwierigen
Rennen in Suzuka das wegen starken
Regens unterbrochen und verkürzt werden
musste
ein kurioses Rennen dazu nicht
ungefährlich Verstappen gewinnt den
Staat gegen leclair im roten Ferrari bei
0 Sicht Sebastian Vettel rutscht dem
Aquaplaning Weg Rennabbruch zu viel
Wasser auf der Strecke nach
Wiederaufnahme wird Vettel 6 da und Max
Verstappen fährt zum Sieg und damit
beginnt die Rechnerei als Charlie Claire
abkürzt um zweiter zu bleiben wird der
bestraft ist nur Dritter hinter Peres
die Strafe von Leclerc mit einberechnet
war klar okay wir sind Weltmeister aber
dann war es wieder nicht weil nicht klar
war wie viel Punkte ich tatsächlich
bekomme jetzt ist es gut ein Verrückter
Tag heute
Verstappen fragt zur Sicherheit nach bin
ich Weltmeister dann setzte sich auf den
WM-Thron 113 Punkte Vorsprung nicht mehr
einzuholen
so schnell wie nie zuvor und mit drei
Neulingen auf dem Podest endete die
ironman-weltmeisterschaft auf Hawaii den
titelsicherte sich nach sieben Stunden
40 Minuten und 24 Sekunden der Norweger
Gustav Iden vor seinem lado aus
Frankreich und idents Landsmann
Christian Blumenfeld bester Deutscher
Sebastian Kienle als Sechster und damit
riss die deutsche Serie von sechs Siegen
nacheinander ist halt manchmal so ist
manchmal so fehlt noch der Blick aufs
Wetter für morgen teils Sonne teils
Wolken am Nachmittag von Nordwesten her
Regen ganz im Westen und Süden
vereinzelt Schauer Höchstwerte 15 bis 22
Grad und das bleibt auch erstmal so erst
am Donnerstag regnet es im Süden das
heute journal um Viertel mit Marietta
Slomka hier übernimmt morgen metri Sirin
wir sagen tschüss wünschen Ihnen einen
guten Start in die neue Woche und geben
wieder direkt ab ins Wahlstudio nach
Hannover zu Bettina Chan